patrick is with us in grand junction
colorado hey patrick how are you
hey dave hey anthony uh thank you so
very much for
taking my call our pleasure how can we
help
well my wife and i read the total money
makeover
uh just two weeks ago wow and
yeah uh i am 41 years old
and we paid off our debt on friday
uh just three days ago wow
well now dave i got to tell you someone
gave me
one of your books when i was like 22
years old
i'm not even kidding you and from that
time till this time i've been on the
dave ramsey envelope system
i have been real serious about not being
debt
i bought my wife's wedding ring for cash
i paid for the wedding in cash
my wife and i have really been blessed
because of the book we read of yours i
mean forever ago
okay so the total money makeover the
other day was just a tune-up then
yeah it was because i i haven't been
listening to the podcast i haven't read
any
more of your books and my wife and i
just looked at where we were and we're
like you know what we need to get on
track
so we only had 12 000 in debt we had one
automobile we paid it off
um i bought the total money makeover
it was the last purchase i made with my
credit card the book came in the mail
and there you are on the cover cutting
up credit cards so i felt like a dumb
dumb for that
blast from me yeah
but here's where here's where we're at
we're on baby step three
and um but we have been investing
a lot of money because we haven't been
on the plan
up until a couple weeks ago so got it my
question is
do i pull some of that out for my six
months
of a fully funded emergency fund or how
much do you have
non-retirement investing
we have 435 000 yes
take enough out today and call it your
emergency fund and put it in a money
market
right now let me explain that to you
because it doesn't make sense
yeah because you're going to hear me cry
in a minute i don't know but it's not
that much money it's not that much money
how much what's your emergency what is
your three to six months of emergencies
how much
should this fund be so we were thinking
six months should be 36 000 okay so move
30 grand that's enough
yeah you'll be fine because you got 400
other than that laying over there right
okay so it's not that much money
now here's the point okay that 30 000
has a
new mission now its old mission
was to grow as an investment
your emergency fund is not an investment
if you can swallow that it'll make this
easier yeah
it's not an investment it's
insurance now if you think about
insurance versus investments
insurance costs you money
to protect the things that make you
money
your house going up right you don't want
to burn
so we buy an insurance policy to protect
it
so insurance is defense investments is
offense so we're moving 30 000 over into
defense
to protect so we don't have to cash out
some of that 400
at exactly the wrong time because let me
tell you what will happen if you think
i'm going to use the 400 if something
happens
that's what most people think yeah what
happens is you'll go
i still can't cash out the 400 even
though i need 7
dollars to do dot dot dot emergency i
just can't do it
and you'll pop it onto a credit card
and so the emergency fund is the
completed
proper step in a good finance in a good
financial plan
but anthony it's very important that we
change it emotionally from offense to
defense
absolutely dave defense is very very
important i love how you called it out
that so you know what
he's going to see that 400 000 over
there he's i don't want to touch that
i'm going go take out a loan
i'm gonna put on the credit card and and
then next thing you know he's right back
into what took him about 20 years to pay
off everything
yeah and so defense sets you up for
effective offense
okay and so i love how bidet broke that
down but
thirty thousand dollars out of four
hundred thousand dollars it's really not
it's not a lot of money yeah you just
ask tampa bay
wow defense sets you up for an effective
offense yeah that was a good one dave
no question i was going for the young
man but man you just hit his heart
without i mean it's just
i i i'm not a fan of either team it's
i'm not i'm not a hater on either team
it's just
just an observation of the game yeah
true you you know it just
sets you up to win and defense wins
games
and defenses and that's that's not only
true in football it's true in finance
and so because here's what can happen
you can be smart smart smart smart smart
smart smart
yeah and then have a moment and this is
not the case
with patrick okay yeah but just as
another example like
i've seen people who build up and they
got 400 grand laying there right
and they've been smart all those years
because patrick's been very smart right
and then suddenly something comes along
that's shiny
this looks like a cool investment that
their friend wants to get them into
and you could put 200 000 over here and
all this
in one stroke of the pen you get stupid
yeah yeah and i've seen people just
suddenly
boom they just lose it yeah and so
that's the that's the you know you've
been really good at offense but you
didn't have a good defense
to keep you from stepping into stupid
tax yeah and i've done it i've never
done it on the stage
by the time i went broke i did it yeah
but i mean since then
i've even done stupid things that cost
me money but i have been smart enough
after i went broke to do them
small enough to where they weren't game
ending and there's one other thing too i
would suggest dave and tell me from
wrong care
that other three hundred and sixty
thousand dollars that he's going to have
there
sitting there give that a give that a
purpose why is it sitting there
it needs to go ahead and do baby steps
four five and six yes
so if you've got a home yeah mortgage
pay off your i'm gonna start moving
towards that with that other with that
other balance that's gonna even be
harder yeah
in another discussion but we'll get
through baby step three first